[Musique]
en fait j'étais en boîte effectivement
aux états unis et j'étais avec un ami à
moi qui est un célèbre street artist la
bac c'est fun mr brainwash et qui a
accès un peu à toutes les stars ouais je
vois le genre tu vois ce gars il est
très sympa ce mec sain français et donc
j'étais en boîte avec lui et il ya de
justin bieber rihanna une table
évidemment être douze mille gardes du
corps et évidemment lui va moi je suis
juste derrière les gardes du corps je
suis vraiment comme ça montré du moment
moi donc ça dure 35 minutes au bout de
35 minutes il doit lui lui ça mon pote
et je rentre et en fait quand je suis là
je sais pas trop quoi leur dire tu vas
un peu gênant donc je parle vite fait
avec avec bieber qui me qui me dit
justin bieber way qui me dit en gros en
gros il me dit coup puisque nous ici on
parle qu'avec bébé le dit écoute il faut
que tu crois en jésus tu crois en jésus
tu aura pas de problème ça c'est le
message n'a pas tort mais ce qui était
marrant c'est avec le verre le truc
l'ambiance sur la base de la base de on
a le colisée si tu crois en jésus y
avait rihanna qui était avec une pote
avec une amie à elle et elle danse en
rampant pompe quoi tu vois ce que je
veux dire et moi je me chauffe dit ok on
danse on n'est pas beaucoup à un peu
derrière elle ouais mais attention en
distance faisons que toi tu es rihanna
rihanna rihanna en bouchage des uc voilà
et moi évidemment je fais tu vois je
danse un peu comme ça
et à un moment donné je me dis ben ouais
j'suis pas choix donc j'irai wayuu et ou
machin c'est un premier regard comme ça
deux jumeaux balayer touazi up du coup
hop je commence un peu à ces et là je me
chauffe
je sais pas toi et elle avait même
l'audace
d'aucuns leurs gammes à j aime l'audace
l uden le baptême l'audace là tu vois
est alors allé mais pas l'audace autant
que ça et du coup on a discuté
j'ai pas une minute trente et les filles
à l'âge était bien alcoolisé et je lui
ai dit écoute moi je sais que j'ai
aucune chance avec toi si tu as envie
d'un mec ce soir d'un mec facile
swarm est fascinant tu prends tu me
prends tu fais ce que tu veux de moi et
elle m'a fait les parties non
[Applaudissements]